hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play super hexagon
now this is another game that you guys
suggested when I asked you on Facebook
and I saw the trailer for it so I have a
good idea what I'm headed towards and
what I'm headed towards seems to be a
whole lot of Hell but let's get into it
because that's what you guys enjoy
watching me struggle and die forever so
I got a gamepad now because L is
recommended and there is no easy level
it just goes hard harder and hardest and
then they got these levels that are
locked oh boy I'm hoping that the
gameplay that I saw in was ninh and
whatever okay so basically you have this
little triangle and you got to control
him I'm ooh oh God oh that's twitchy as
hell oh god oh god
uh-uh-uh-uh and you got to get it
through these hexagons without touching
the sides ah my brain oh oh my god I
died I think and I am entirely sure what
just happened
now I have a seizure did I stroke out do
I smell rotten eggs what the hell is
going on here can't just do that to me
man can't just do that to me
I barely started oh good golly this is
not gonna be happy fun times I can tell
you that right now oh my god oh yeah I'm
it's really difficult to get it exactly
where I want to go because it's very
imprecise you got to hold down the
buttons to get it go far but oh my god
oh my god
this is go god oh god oh god oh no no no
oh no I can't even sing a word with the
world oh it's fun the world and spun the
things at the same time or was I just
like was a dream anything god damn did
someone load up a cannon with LSD and
shoot me in the face what the hell is
going on here oh my god I don't even
know what you need to do to beat it what
are you talking about like lying in
triangle and whatever I don't know what
they're saying oh good god how's
anyone's house any normal human supposed
to be oh wait why I made excellent you
changed it on me Oh oh good good you
changed it on me I saw that you're
trying to trick me you bastards why
would you do that you son of a I'm
just in a state of panic right now
because I don't know what's going on I
don't know if I died and went to hell
or if this is just what life is now then
what in what world what a human needs
skills to do this my enderal you did it
again you son of a don't think I
Olga oh no no - ah they're reducing it
what Oh God Oh
what are you doing stop stop oh that was
actually I shouldn't have even died then
because oh my god this is impossible how
is anyone supposed to be able to do this
one of my Enders from Ender's Game as
well I was trying to stay cool let's go
fly go bomb this is unbelievable this is
incredible I mean it's really cool I
love the music and I love the bumping
bass behind it I guess I guess that's
cool and all but
but at what cost what cost you sacrifice
your entire life to master this game and
what do you get out of rewarded well put
on your resume well I can move a
triangle really quickly back and forth
through an ever-changing universe if the
world our 3-dimensional world ever turns
into multiple dimensions I'll be ready
and then you get them in then you never
get hired anywhere because he's been
your life playing this game and learning
these useless skills oh my god I'm never
gonna be I'm getting progressively worse
by the way I got I got to 40 something
seconds and then um
I'm never ever I'm gonna never ever ever
ever ever ever what the hell there's
enough time to get through I gotta take
my pants off for this one guys this is
ridiculous I got I'll be right back
the pants are off oh and that's not
weird by the way everyone knows you have
better reaction times in the aren't
wearing pants let's just say that right
now
I don't even know what I need to do to
beat this is this endless mode there
were different difficulties but I said I
needed to beat him well duh that was a
flute that was a pant I'm still
calibrating to my pants to the state
everyone just hold on to your hat don't
ask me why I needed to do that I just
felt the urge feel the urge oh okay this
I'm noticing a pattern when I go through
that it always does look like the
triplet thing and then this is a spiral
that's easy to get through and it's like
yeah the triple c thing but then it
tries to change dimensions on you and
then it goes faster and then it moves it
around
ah see it changes from a four
dimensional stare six dimensional state
to a five dimensional state ah ha ha
I got you're always okay I um goddammit
I always had that I just it's it's the
controls are very finicky it's it's hard
to get exactly where I want to go and
stop and start cuz I mean it's not I
don't move in solid chunks I just move
free form it is very very difficult hang
on just just give me a second I'm
getting this by roll bio total baby yeah
I almost went too far there just because
it was very Wow all that's not a spiral
god damn it it's tricking me
it's fixies Trixie orbited Italy this
isn't this isn't Gollum I don't know who
this is but they are those Trixie
hobbitses I'm spitting everywhere now we
gotta get the spit to properly lubricate
the spiral miss nature of all say it's
imprecise
I barely went over oh god I think I can
I think I stopped where I go but I don't
it ends up that I don't okay anyone ah
God huh like if it's hard
I would I would imagine that I would be
doing better if I didn't have to talk at
the same time like seriously you try to
like balance on your head while rub
patting your head rubbing your stomach
and then like coming up with freeform
commentary at the same time it's rather
difficult but do say so myself and
that's why going into my bag of tricks
and all I got is being me they would
voice it yeah is this funny yet in here
mold Oh Oh God not the C thing okay
Triple C aw see god damn in there
shrinks it goes for I think there's some
changing in the sensitivity of what I'm
going based on where it is Wow baby nah
maybe I'm just being a whiner maybe I'm
being a big old bull blowing baby here
and I should just suck it up and move on
but I must reiterate this feels as
though I am an epileptic squid on LSD
also known as aa did yes it I could use
some after this damn I mean this can do
my god least I got the music I must I
see when I get when it gets smaller like
that it becomes more sensitive or not er
I don't know it just changes the
perception of where I am and what I'm
doing it it's rather difficult that's
all I'm gonna say this game that's all I
have to say really it's oh god I was the
wrong way it's rather difficult just
need pretty hard that's what she said
that's not even rage worthy I mean I
understand the mechanics of it it's not
unfair like certain games it's it is
what it is it's not gonna change the I
mean it does change everyone so long got
a funfair get a douchey in that regard
but I mean at least the rules are
consistent for now I don't know the
harder difficulties are like believe for
now being sorta yeah I got it look a
wrong way
when it was six it was evil even to go
one way or another way if it's five it
was always a ha God never mind I'm not
even gonna explain myself I'm not even
gonna try to explain myself because for
one I can't even explain this game why
would I be able to explain my own
actions Oh God if I if I try to filter
out the noise it's not actually its most
of them most of the visual distractions
come from the spinning if it wasn't
spinning I figured this would be a lot
easier to make the right choices on
where to go because like fundamentally
it's not that complex the shape is very
regular it's very sensible there are
certain patterns as to what obstacles it
will throw at you and if you look
closely and look farther out you're
actually able to see a path of where
you're supposed to go but right now it's
just really hard cuz I'm talking at the
same time oh man if it's not clear how
challenging this is like even though
it's like I say fundamentally it's it's
not her if eclis complex it still it's
so pretty hard ah you did the thing on
me Oh God was this one ah come on EDD
that okay huh alright just throw me in a
pit of hell and kill me right now
because I do not want to go through this
anymore
I'm never gonna be able to beat this my
records what 40 seconds I'm never gonna
get past that I don't even know what you
need to do to get past that oh ho ho
elbows ran right into that one line line
line a and line line line y'all change
dimensions on me yeah sure is your
bested Babu dabba doo oh god damn it I
didn't overshoot that not even a little
bit ah
now comes the frustration because I know
what to do and I basically I basically
figured out how to play this game it's
just now I'm getting angry because I'm
getting messed up by stupid ass things
oh wow are you kidding me mother humph
mother of humph
yes I'm good yeah yes people have
commented that I asked a lot like
jontron now and I just I really like
John John's videos and I watch him over
and over again and I just start out yeah
now I've been watching game grumps in
watching the old John dried-up is open
yeah yeah yeah this game just oh yeah
that's what happens I mean who wouldn't
get nauseous playing this game Oh God
well the music is good reminds me of
like electronic super joy in terms of
music and stylistically wise well I
guess stylistically because pixelated
one done low res but still holy hell
okay I can see it get your money out
money's worth in this game if you tried
to actually beat it because this game
was only 3 bucks but goddamn you'd be
playing this for hours trying to beat it
name it oh come on budge how damn it I'm
trying not to get mad I understand it's
not an unfair game it's all a scale
thing at this point
oh god your notices come on come on let
me concentrate here let me just
concentrate everybody's shut up for two
seconds of limit concentrate ah all you
changed it I knew that was coming it
does that it changes the Pentagon than
the square oh it's a four thing when it
goes to the Pentagon I'm thinking three
and it goes for god damnit
Oh wanna beat it but it's really hard
it's really hard
oh come on come on is
Oh God and win it it goes off of the
two-dimensional plane that's when things
get a little wonky on me Oh God do you
guys even know what if only there was
not enough time how was I supposed oh oh
one more try one more thing I'm not
gonna do this much longer because I
don't think I can handle it
he handle it I'll be mad I'm bound Evan
I'm bound how did I even make it that
far the first time I like made it to 40
seconds among one of the first times I
was playing this game I thought I was
progressively gonna get better but this
beginner's frickin luck apparently -
dang it don't you mess up on me don't
you dig with me did you see how unfair
that was that was not my fault there was
like a BEC so uh it's all because it
flipped formed hmm oh how it always
works out I say I'm not gonna get mad
cuz oh my god damn it all right god damn
Oh God oh my god this is how I died my
heart's gonna explode Matt's gonna blow
up into a million bitty bitty pieces I
go the wrong way every time on that last
one of the four thing Oh Oh God
oh god I gotta get this line don't judge
me you guys wouldn't fare any better the
majority of you goddamn it and remember
I just started playing fully been
playing for 110 minutes give me a break
don't judge me so harshly don't do it
don't do it guys
come on I'm just a normal person I'm a
human being with hopes and dreams of
eventually getting out of this hellhole
of a prison oh my god oh my god
shut up lady I know what I hear it haha
what SS
this isn't squares it squares why is it
squares no anymore
oh god what's going on anymore
the hell Oh 59 ah god I almost had 60
seconds I would have loved or got into
60 seconds Podge okay I'm done that was
probably the best I'm ever gonna do so
before you whatever hadn't died at the
end because of a stupid that look how
close look how close into the next
section I was whatever whatever I don't
care anymore I don't care I'm done okay
I'm done alright you want to think you
think you're gonna bury me I'm out love
fit you know what I love does it because
this game um I'm done I'm done I'm done
59 seconds good enough for me it ever
make okay all right okay all right okay
all right okay all right hey you in the
next video